B.S.
>> WOW, AMAZING TAKE, RUSH
LIMBAUGH CALLING OTT JIM
LIMBAUGH CALLING OUT JIM
CLAPPER.
JUNE 5TH, BARNES AND NOBLE.COM.
YOU CAN PREORDER.
>> IT'S LIKE A DAILY TORTURE.
WE'LL GET THE NEWS AND MAKE SURE
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT HIS NEW
BOOK.
WE ARE GOING TO DO AN HOUR ON MY
RADIO SHOW, AN HOUR SPECIAL.
I THINK IT'S SO FUNNY.
HE'S A GENIUS.
>> I SAID, GOT INTO THIS WITH
LAURA.
SHE SHOWED ME THE CLAPPER STUFF.
HE DOESN'T LIKE TALKING ABOUT
SPYING.
I COULDN'T HELP MYSELF I SAID HE
WAS THE NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF
INTELLIGENCE.
HE WAS IN CHARGE OF EVERY SPY WE
HAVE.
HOW CAN YOU HAVE A DIRECTOR OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT DOESN'T LIKE
SPYING?
THE WHOLE THING IS CRAZY.
>> YOU ARE ONE OF THE SMALLEST
PEOPLE I KNOW.
>> IT'S A SMALL CIRCLE
>> WE HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER A
LONG TIME.
HERE'S WHERE WE ARE.
HILLARY COMMITS FELONIES,
OBSTRUCTS JUSTICE, WE COVER IT
UP, WRITING ABOUT EXONERATION
MONTH BEFORE IT'S DISCUSSED.
NOW WE HAVE SPIES IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
WE HAVE FYZA JUDGES LIED TO,
HILARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR DOSSIER THAT THE AUTHOR
SAID, WRONG INTELLIGENCE, MAYBE
50/50.
THAT BECAME THE BASIS FOR A FYZA
WARRANT AND THREE SUBSEQUENT
RENEWALS.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST CORRUPTION
ABUSE OF POWER WE HAVE EVER
SEEN?
>> BY A HUGE MARGIN.
I TALKED ABOUT THIS ON THE RADIO
SHOW.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SHOW THIS.
WE HAVE THE CLINTON CORRUPTION
GOING BACK MANY YEARS, BACK TO
CATTLE FEATURES WHERE THE WALL
STREET JOURNEY FIGURED OUT IT
WAS MATHEMATICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
MAKE THAT MUCH MONEY HONESTLY.
THEY HAVE BEEN GETTING AWAY WITH
IT SINCE 1990.
THEN YOU HAVE THE PEOPLE THAT
COVERED UP FOR HER CORRUPTION,
THE EA
THE E-MAILS AS PART OF THE
CORRUPTION.
THAT'S A SECOND LAYER.
THEN YOU HAVE THE FEAR, TRUMP
COULD WIN AND A THIRD LAYER, THE
PEOPLE PROTECTING HER, THERE WAS
A WONDERFUL LINE, HE WROTE,
DEMOCRATS GET AWAY WITH MURDER
AND REPUBLICANS GET MURDERED.
NOW HERE IS WHAT I BEGAN TO
REALIZE IN THE LAST FEW DAYS,
ALL OF A SUDDEN THE GUYS THAT
PLANNED TO BASK IN CORRUPTION
REALIZE THEY COULD BE INDICTED
AND CONVICTED.
I HAVE KNOWN CLAPPER FOR YEARS.
HE USED TO BE A SERIOUS
PROFESSIONAL.
THE GUY I SEE ON T.V. NOW IS
PATHETIC.
>> WHAT ABOUT BRENNAN?
>> ONLY OBAMA WOULD PICK A
COMMUNIST TO BE HEAD OF THE FBI.
BRENNAN HAS THE PROBLEM, COMEY
HAS THE PROBLEM, MCNAB HAS THE
PROBLEM, LYNCH HAS THE PROBLEM.
YOU ARE GOING TO FIND OUT IT
GOES TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> NO DOUBT.
>> ZERO DOUBT.
I CAN'T IMAGINE BARACK OBAMA NOT
KNOWING.
>> IF THE TRUTH COMES OUT, IT
WILL GO TO THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE
AND POWER AND THE REST OF THEM.
>> GIVEN THE WAY THEY RAN A
TIGHT OPERATION.
DOES ANYONE BELIEVE VALERIE
JARRETT DIDN'T KNOW THIS STUFF?
>> THEY GAVE THE NEW YORK TIMES
TO SPIN IT.
THEY REVEALED WHEN THE TRIP TOOK
PLACE TO GREAT BRITAIN, DEEP
NEGOTIATIONS WITH DOWNER, WITH
OUR STATE DEPARTMENT, THAT HAD
TO BE AT THE TOP FOR HIM TO
ALLOW THE INTERVIEW BY THE FBI.
>> THE GUY WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
WHO IS NOT IDENTIFIED AND ALL
THIS BOLOGNA WHO GOT A MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE DEEP STATE.
>> TWO YEARS.
YOU START SAYING, OH, IT'S
OKAY -- AND WHAT I READ WAS
ENTRAPMENT.
>> HE'S SAYING TO THIS GUY, COME
ON, GIVE ME, GIVE ME.
>> THERE WAS EVEN A CUTE BLONDE.
>> THERE AIN'T NOTHING THERE.
>> HILLARY WINS, NOTARY PUBLIC
OF
NONE OF THISCOMES OUT.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET TO THE TRUTH?
>> NO.
>> NEITHER AM I.
>> WHAT IT'S GOING TO COME DOWN
TO IS WHETHER OR NOT THE
PRESIDENT CAN KEEP FOCUSED.
>> HE IS.
>> HE IS NOW.
THIS IS GOING TO GO ON TWO AND
THREE YEARS.
>> THEY ARE SETTING TRAPS FOR
HIM TO GET MAD AND FIRE.
>> DIGGING THE STUFF OUT, MAKING
THE CONNECTIONS.
WHAT IS JEFF SESSIONS DOING?
WHAT IS WRONG WITH HIM?
>> IF WE HAD AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL?
>> WE DO, ROB ROSEN STEIN.
>> I'M SO SADDENED BY JEFF
SESSIONS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM.
HIS INABILITY TO DO HIS SCOB.
>>
JOB.
>> SCARY.
>> HE'S A GUY I LIKED FOR A LONG
TIME.
HE JUST FOLDED.